en el vídeo pasado vimos cómo calcular
el trabajo necesario para mover una
carga en un campo eléctrico constante lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es lo
mismo pero ahora nuestro campo eléctrico
va a ser variable eso nos va a ayudar a
determinar la energía potencial
eléctrica de una carga con respecto a un
punto vale bueno para todo esto vamos a
empezar con una carga puntual que voy a
poner por aquí voy a poner por aquí la
edad no tiene por qué ser una carga
puntual pero nos ayuda a pensar un poco
más las cosas entonces está ya que es
una carga puntual y le voy a poner más q
un culo más es una carga de un culo mbps
y es positiva vale y bueno aquí ya vamos
viendo que tiene un campo eléctrico
distinto al del vídeo pasado porque el
campo eléctrico generado con esta carga
ahora sí es variable verdad de hecho
está dado en términos de la fórmula que
teníamos antes que nos dice que el campo
eléctrico el campo eléctrico es igual a
la constante de colom por la carga q no
por la carga q uno dividido entre el
radio al cuadrado
entonces dependiendo de a qué distancia
estemos vamos a tener un distinto campo
eléctrico o bueno una distinta magnitud
del campo eléctrico entonces vamos a
hacer el dibujo de cómo se vería ese
campo eléctrico y para eso voy a poner
los vectores para que van saliendo de
aquí es decir pongo por aquí una carga
positiva y veo hacia dónde se iría
aquí como está muy cerca pues entonces
estamos dividiendo entre algo chiquito y
por lo tanto tendríamos una magnitud
grande que va radialmente hacia afuera
vemos similar si estamos por aquí pues
vamos a tener también que radialmente
hacia afuera nos alejamos fuertemente y
de hecho si este punto y este punto
están a la misma distancia entonces
estos vectores deberían de tener la
misma longitud voy a dibujar otros
cuantos más o menos a esta misma a esa
misma distancia otro por acá
mirando de ser de la misma longitud de a
lo mejor no me está quedando muy muy
bien pero bueno entonces eso es estando
pues aquí de cerquita pero si nos
alejamos un poco más entonces ahora va a
disminuir el tamaño de las flechitas
verdad o de los vectores podemos pensar
esto como un campo vectorial entonces a
lo mejor aquí ya no ya no sale tanto ya
son flechas un poco más chiquitas
también por acá pero siempre van hacia
afuera están entonces siempre va hacia
afuera y hacia afuera por acá serían más
chiquitas bueno se ve la idea verdad
esto nada más es un repaso de lo que ya
habíamos platicado y pues resulta que
justo las longitudes de estos vectores
van disminuyendo con el cuadrado de la
distancia vale ok entonces aquí tenemos
un dibujo del campo eléctrico así es
como se ve y pues tiene bastante sentido
verdad y todo esto venía de la ley de
colom porque si poníamos otra carga q 2
esto sigue siendo un repaso pero si
poníamos otra carga q 2 por acá voy a
ponerla digamos por acá
y poníamos otra carga q2 y pensamos que
también es positiva entonces para
encontrar la fuerza que ejerce el campo
de ésta sobre ésta lo que tenemos que
hacer es multiplicar esta carga por el
campo eléctrico entonces tendríamos que
la fuerza que la fuerza es igual a la
carga por el campo eléctrico y
finalmente nos queda igual a
reacomodando cada por q1 por q 2 y eso
dividido dividido entre la distancia al
cuadrado que es justo la ley de colombia
entonces bueno todo tiene mucho sentido
hasta ahorita vale entonces vamos a
tomar esta carga q2 y vamos a pensar que
es positiva entonces como ya dijimos se
va a alejar de esta carga de curriculums
lo que quiero hacer ahorita es
determinar el trabajo necesario para
empujar esta carga a cierta distancia
hacia adentro entonces vamos a hacerlo
según el siguiente diagrama vamos a
pensar que esta carga la queremos
acercar bueno vamos a pensar que
inicialmente déjame tomar otro color que
inicialmente esta carga está
no se deja no ponerle 10 metros
10 metros y que queremos acercarla hasta
la mitad aquí hasta los 5 metros
entonces estoy acá sería 5 metros
esto es acá sería 5 metros vale queremos
mover esta carga 5 metros hacia acá
entonces la pregunta es cuánto trabajo
necesitamos para hacer eso
q1 y q2 pues no son numeritos entonces
nuestra respuesta nos va a quedar en
términos de q no de q2
quizás la constante de colom pero aquí
sí vamos a poder meter el radio vale
entonces cómo le hacemos para determinar
esto bueno pues para encontrar el
trabajo tenemos que ver la fuerza que
aplicamos por la distancia pero ahora la
fuerza que tenemos que aplicar en cada
momento va cambiando porque la fuerza
que causa este campo eléctrico que
ejerce este campo eléctrico va variando
entonces bueno para hacer las cosas ata
cables para que podamos resolver el
problema lo que vamos a pensar es que en
un pequeño cambio voy a ponerlo con
color rojo
vamos a pensar que en un pequeño cambio
la fuerza que necesitamos es constante
entonces a este pequeño cambio me voy a
poner de r es un cambio infinitesimal
así minúsculo y si ya empezamos a hablar
de cosas infinitesimales estos son una
cálculo así que bueno si si si no te
acuerdas de cálculo ve a repasar los
vídeos y bueno si no sabes cálculo sería
bueno que los ché caras para aprender de
estas cosas que vamos a platicar pero
bueno entonces la cosa es que aquí en un
pequeño cambio podemos pensar que la
fuerza es constante y que está dada de
la de la forma o sea justo por estar acá
por q no por q 2 dividido entre cuadrada
vale entonces el trabajo el pequeño
trabajo que vamos a realizar aquí vamos
a llamarle así de w
el pequeño trabajo que realizamos en
este caso va a ser igual a la fuerza que
estamos ejerciendo por la pequeña
distancia que nos estamos moviendo por
de r ahora ojo cuidado aquí tengo que
poner un signo menos
porque pues bueno porque el campo está
ejerciendo esta fuerza esta fuerza hacia
afuera pero nosotros queremos mover esta
carga hacia adentro hacia adentro 5
metros entonces justo tenemos que
compensar la fuerza que causa este campo
eléctrico vale hacia adentro hacia el
otro lado quizás un poquito más para que
la carga se empiece a mover pero ya que
ejercimos un poquito más ya nada más es
necesario hacer esta pero hacia adentro
y por eso tiene un signo menos va bueno
entonces ahora sí si estoy aquí es el
pequeño trabajo que hay que realizar en
este caso como le hacemos para calcular
el trabajo total ahora sí déjame ponerlo
así como lo hacemos para calcular así el
trabajo total pues lo que tenemos que
hacer es sumar una infinidad de estos
cambios así infinitamente pequeños todos
estos pequeños de r entonces si estamos
hablando de una suma infinita de cambios
pues infinitamente pequeños eso es
claramente una integral vale entonces
déjame plantear la integral entonces el
trabajo el trabajo que tenemos que
realizar lo voy a poner
si por aquí tengo espacio entonces el
trabajo que tenemos que realizar es
igual a la integral y de dónde a dónde
tenemos que movernos pues de 10
de 10 a 5 de todo esto de acá entonces
es menos acá
q 2 dividido entre re cuadrada de r vale
se puede ver un poco raro que los
límites de integración abajo este grande
y arriba esté el pequeño pero se debe a
que nos estamos bien que nos estamos
moviendo de distancia 10 a distancia 5
vale vamos de 10 a 5 ok vamos a resolver
esta integral no es tan fea como parece
mira vamos a sacar todas las constantes
que es menos cara q1 q2 menos k q1 q2
por la integral de 10 a 5 este ere
cuadrada lo voy a poner como un ere a la
menos 2 de r y esta integral es fácil de
hacer
es una ley estoy aquí es algo elevado a
un exponente entonces podemos hacerlo de
la siguiente forma
esto nos queda igual a menos k q1 q2
y hacemos esta integral y real a menos 2
tenemos que sumarle 1 al exponente nos
queda irreal a menos 1 y hay que
multiplicar por menos porque estamos
dividiendo entre este menos vale si
quieres puedes verificar que al derivar
efectivamente nos da el real a menos 2
pero bueno ya tenemos aquí la anti
derivada y esa la tenemos que evaluar en
5 y restarle la evaluación en 10 y vamos
a ver qué nos queda este menos con este
menos los voy a juntar para que se hagan
un más
entonces me queda acá q1 q2
y adentro del paréntesis que me queda
sería era la menos 1 evaluado en 5 que
es un quinto menos era la menos 1
evaluado en 10 que es un decir sí y esto
cuánto sería pues haber un quinto menos
un décimo cuanto es un quinto son dos
décimos dos décimos menos un décimo es
un décimo entonces esto es igual acá por
q1 por q 2 entre 10 va entonces esto de
acá
estoy acá es el trabajo que necesitamos
hacer para mover nuestra carga de este
punto a este punto de acá de modo
similar podemos decir que esta carga
cuando está en este punto de aquí tiene
una energía potencial eléctrica de cada
uno q 2 / 10 déjame le pongo por aquí
llorís
jules tiene una tiene una energía
potencial eléctrica de cada uno q 2 / 16
con respecto a y recuerda que eso es
importante con respecto a este punto de
acá
bueno vamos a dejarle hasta aquí y en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a ver otro
concepto interesante nos vemos pronto